that is nothing but a bunch of tea
banging rednecks angry government and a
bang and racism and a conservative
movement has now crystallized into the
White Power movement who are ill into
killing blacks and jews and women or
whatever it may be I haven't met any
races yet be honest with you not in the
tea party have you yourself is anyone
accused you of racism for your
involvement the tea party today yes I've
been called a couple of bad words today
there are cult Nazis fascist
all-american braces any opposition you
have any opposition to Obama to the
Democratic Party anything right now the
way to end any argument racist this is
racism straight up they say racist and
the arguments over how can that be I
mean there is freedom of speech but you
know that comes with the responsibility
I think this is dangerous rhetoric
they're fascist Stooges who in the true
sense of that word that's not hyperbole
and you know we see these hate groups
rising up and this is definitely part of
that no I see a lot of anger for the
government but I don't see anything the
media's has told every one of these
blind is blind in this guided people
that the Tea Party is racist so that so
that you know african-americans and
other other groups and Democrats won't
participate in something which would
definitely help out their children you
can't deal with these people at all that
that's what they want to do they want to
categorize us to where we are fighting
each other I think they're threatened
and they're afraid we're going to win so
they're trying like how can we bring you
down oh the worst thing you could be in
this country is this is about hating a
black man y'all switch to the first time
i heard obama speak i thought there's a
guy that knows we talk goodbye he speaks
very very long but he has converted it
socialism tape from the people who are
working and get to those who aren't you
are unamerican you are anti-american you
do not love this country and you were
rooting against america they see
millions of people in this country
asking the question among themselves and
with
in their neighborhoods are these fools
in Washington gonna wreck our country
and it scared them half to death
you